كيف تقرا هذا التركيز وتركيز الاشتباكات
الضاريه في خان يونس في هذا التوقيت من
المعركه الدائره منذ
شهور محمود الهدف دائما هو الانتقال الى
المرحله الثالثه هذا ما قاله وزير الامن
او وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف جالنت
عندما قال انه هناك رؤيه لمرحله للمرحله
الثالثه تقوم على تطويق مدينه غزه القيام
بعمليات عندما ترى ذلك ضروره القوات
الاسرائيليه ولكن تدمير اكيد بالطبع حسب
ما يدعي تدمير قدره حماس
وبالتالي عدم وجود اي اسرائيلي في القطاع
والانتقال الى حكم غزه وليس من من حماس
اليوم العائق الاساسي لا يزال في الشمال
المعركه الكبرى هي في الوسط ولكن خان يونس
لا تزال
هي اذا صح التعبير العقبه الكبرى لاستكمال
هذا المشروع يعني ان تقول ان هناك مشروع
هو ليس كما التطبيق على الارض
ولكن الشيء الجديد اليوم هو تكثيف القصف
على شرق القطاع او وسط شرق القطاع وفي
خزاعه وكاننا نذهب الى مرحله اخلاء هذه
المنطقه تدميرها لانشاء ما يسمى بالمنطقه
العازله ا لكن كما تفضلت مازال هناك
اشتباكات في الشمال مازال هناك اشتباكات
في الوسط وفي مدينه غزه في قلبها هل يفترض
بنا ان نعود الى المربع الاول من هذه
الحرب كلما بدا يعني طبعا انا اتحدث بعقل
اسرائيلي كلما بدا اننا يعني او كان
الاسرائيليين ينجزون مرحله ما من هذه
الحرب نعود الى المربع الاول مجددا ونجد
ان الشمال تنطلق منه رشاقات صاروخيه كبيره
باتجاه المدن والبلدات الاسرائيليه الكبرى
ايضا وليس فقط في غلاف غزه
هذا هو الهاجس الاكبر والذي ادى يعني
طبيعه الارض وما عكسته وما عكسه الميدان
بالمعنى العسكري والتكتيكي انعكس محمود
على واقع الخلاف السياسي الذي حصل ضمن
الاجتماع الحكومه يعني اليوم دخلت القوات
الاسرائيليه الى شمال غزه لانهاء الشجاعيه
وحتى انهاء واحتلال مدينه غزه لم لم
تستطيع ان تحقق كل الاهداف عندما انسحبت
ايضا بدات العمليات العسكريه ضد هذه
القوات يعني هي عندما تدخل تدفع ثمن
وعندما تخرج تدفع ثمن ولكن موضوع الصواريخ
التي تطلق من الشمال او حتى من الوسط لها
بعد اخر مختلف محمود هي عمليه ربط النزاع
بين الداخل في في في قطاع في قطاع غزه
وربطه بالداخل الفل بالداخل الاسرائيلي
كان تقول انك مهما فعلت ستستمر هذه
الصواريخ وبالتالي لا يمكن الفصل ومفهوم
المنطقه العازله هو مفهوم واهن ولا يمكن
ان يؤمن الامن الاسرائيلي الكثافه الناريه
يفترض انها محسومه لصالح الطرف الاسرائيلي
الذي يحصل على اسلحه بلا حدود واحدث
الانظمه العسكريه في مقابل مجموعه محاصره
منذ عشرات السنين في قطاع او منذ سنوات
عديده في داخل قطاع ضيق تفتخ الى ابسط
المقاومات الماليه والعسكريه او الماديه
التي تضمن لها التفوق رغم ذلك الوقائع على
الارض تشير الى ما نعرضه يوميا بهذه
الصوره كيف تستمر هذه المعادله برايك
ا محمود هو ليس بالكم هو بالكيف يعني
طبيعه القتال بالنسبه لحماس والمقاومه شيء
وطبيعه القتال بالنسبه للعسكر الاسرائيلي
شيء اخر يعني حماس من خلال الانفاق ورسم
وتحضير الارضيه للسيناريو السيء استطاعت
ان تحيد الكثير من التفوق والتقدم
التكنولوجي الاسرائيلي من هنا عمليه
الدمار لغزه واستشهاد ما يقارب 22000 شهيد
حتى الان ولكن اليوم حماس تقاتل بما توفر
ومن صناعه محليه ضد احدث تكنولوجيه من
جيوش العالم ولكن هي في طريقه الاستعمال
وهنا الهاجس الاكبر لاسرائيل هو عدم
القدره على قياس النجاح ا طيب برايك
ايضا تزامن ما يحدث في قطاع غزه مع سخونه
الجبهه الشماليه والصواريخ التي والقذائف
التي تنطلق من جنوب لبنان نحو الجليل
الاعلى ونحو بعض مستوطنات الشمال الى اي
مدن يؤثر على سير العمليات في قطاع
غزه
يعني كما قال امين عام حزب الله هي
للتثبيت والاشغال وهذا الامر متعلق بغزه
حتى الان لم ترتقي هذه العمليات الى مستوى
حرب هي ضمن قواعد اشتباك محدوده اليوم او
البارحه استعمل حزب الله عن من جديد قذائف
البركان وهي قذائف قد تصل الى
300500 كيلوغرام كراس حربي ولكن على مسافه
قصيره وكانه يقول ان هناك تصعيد بعد
اغتيال القياده في حماس في بيروت ولكن ليس
الى مستوى الحرب الشامله
والكامله